wenn du auf deinem Balkon noch
Blumentöpfe mit alter Erde hast musst du
die nicht wegwerfen du kannst die Erde
stattdessen einfach auffrischen richtig
fruchtbar machen und sie ganz einfach
wieder verwenden ohne dass du dabei
einbßen bei deiner nächsten Ernte hast
zumindest nicht in den allermeisten
Fällen auf die Ausnahmen komme ich
natürlich auch noch zu sprechen auf
meinem Kanal gebe ich dir jede Menge
Tipps für eine dicke fette Gemüseernte
also gerne abonnieren deine grünen
Freunde werden es dir danken als erstes
brauchen wir eine große oder einen
Maurerkübel wir pimpen nämlich jetzt die
alte Erde richtig auf und dann kommen
deine alten Töpfe oder Kübel ins Spiel
wahrscheinlich stehen da ja noch alte
abgestorbene Pflanzen in deinen Kübeln
die Pflanzenreste holst du jetzt mit dem
Wurzelballen aus dem Topf heraus und
schüttelt den Wurzelballen im Topf gut
aus S dass wir möglichst viel Erde
auffangen und retten die Pflanzenreste
und den Ballen kannst du dann
kompostieren das machen wir z.B in ein
bokashiimer du kannst auch eine
Wurmkiste nehmen die passen nämlich
beide super gut auf einen kleinen Balkon
und so kannst du auch auf einer winzigen
Fläche z.B in ein Stadtwohnung deinen
eigenen Dünger aus Pflanzenresten
herstellen oder du sammelst die
Pflanzenreste und schneidest die klein
um deine neuen Pflanzen dann damit zu
mulchen die Erde die in unseren Töpfen
zurückbleibt sammeln wir dann in dem
großen Behälter wenn da große Erdklumpen
dabei sind dann zerkleinerst du die
einfach so gut es geht mit deinen Händen
bis die Erde wieder richtig fluffig ist
du kannst die Erde auch sieben aber das
ist nicht unbedingt nötig und jetzt
gibst du noch ein Drittel neue
Blumenerde oder Kompost dazu ich achte
immer darauf torfreie Blumenerde zu
kaufen weil der Torfabbau eine richtig
große ökologische Katastrophe ist und
man wirklich keinen Torf braucht um
richtig tolles balkongemüse anzubauen
und dann sorgen wir noch für frische
Nährstoffe für die alte Erde die können
aus dem Kompost von deiner Wurmkiste
stammen oder aus dem bokashisaft wenn du
schon deinen eigenen Dünger herstellst
oder du nimmst einen gekauften
biologischen Langzeitdünger wenn du dich
fragst wie viel Dünger du verwenden
solltest dann schau am besten auf die
Packung weil das bei jedem Hersteller
unterschiedlich ist ich achte aber
darauf dass ich beim Auffrischen immer
nur ganz leicht aufdünge weil ich ja zu
dem Zeitpunkt noch gar nicht weiß welche
Pflanzen später in der Erde wachsen
werden und ein Salat hat z.B einen viel
geringeren Nährstoffbedarf als eine
Tomatenpflanze und damit wir keine
Pflanze überdüngen nehme ich immer nur
relativ wenig Dünger beim aufrischen der
Erde was ich aber immer in rauen Mengen
dazu gebe sind pro volle Mörtelwanne
ungefähr 300 g aktivierte Pflanzenkohle
und ungefähr 200 g Urgesteinsmehl das
gibt nämlich noch mal einen richtigen
fruchtbarkeitsboost die Menge an
Urgesteinsmehl kannst du auch variieren
je nachdem ob du später starkzerer oder
schwachzerre anbauen möchtest also
Pflanzen die viele Nährstoffe brauchen
oder weniger Nährstoffe übrigens nicht
wundern der Balkon den ihr hier seht den
begärtnern wir mit unserem ganzen Büro
deswegen bin nicht immer nur ich in den
Videos zu sehen sondern z.B auch meine
liebe Kollegin melena hier seht ihr wie
sie alles gründlich vermischt das ist
nämlich der nächste Schritt und dann
kannst du die Erde für die nächste
pflanzrunde wieder verwenden und je
nachdem zu welchen Himmelsrichtungen
dein Balkon ausgerichtet ist kannst du
ja unterschiedliche Pflanzen auf deinem
Balkon anbauen und wenn du gerade
überlegst was bei dir als nächstes
wachsen soll aber dir nicht so ganz
sicher bist was auf deinem Balkon
eigentlich möglich ist dann lad dir
gerne meinen balkonkompass runter der
ist gerade fertig geworden und da kannst
du auf einen Blick alle Pflanzen ablesen
die auf deinem Balkon wachsen würden den
balkonkompass verlinke ich dir im
obersten angepinnten Kommentar und da
findest du auch die Links zum
Urgesteinsmehl zum Langzeitdünger und
zur Pflanzenkohle du solltest aber nur
die Erde von Töpfen wieder verwenden in
denen gesunde Pflanzen gewachsen sind
weil du sonst riskierst dass sich
Krankheiten oder Schädlinge wieder
schnell auf deinem Balkon ausbreiten
wenn deine Pflanzen krank waren oder von
Schädlingen befallen waren dann solltest
du die Erde und die Pflanzenreste
entsorgen und die Töpfe gut sauber
machen bevor du sie mit komplett
frischer Erde wieder auffüllst wusstest
du dass man auf einem Balkon richtig
viele Kartoffeln ernten kann und dass
eine Blaubeere die man im Kübel anbaut
bis zu 17 kg pro Jahr tragen kann falls
dich das interessiert verlink ich dir
hier die passenden Videos und ansonsten
geh raus mach die Welt ein bisschen
grüner und wir sehen uns im nächsten
Video wieder bis dann tschüss